hey good evening everybody and welcome
to this evening's planning committee
meeting my name is peter richards i will
be sharing tonight's meeting
a few uh a few housekeepings uh things
to start with if you could please turn
all your devices to mute
particularly mobile phones i don't mind
if you want to use your mobile phones um
but provided they don't interrupt the
process and flow of this meeting so if
you could please turn them silent that'd
be great um we are being uh filmed and
live broadcast um as we speak uh this
will be presented on our website and on
youtube for later viewing so please be
aware of that
um
we don't have any fire alarms uh planned
so if one does go off follow us out to
the main car park and we will just make
sure that everyone's got out safely as
well
um if i could uh
while i think about it um the meeting is
also um a meeting in public it is not a
public meeting so um i will only be
calling those people that have
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so i will call on you at the
appropriate time for you to come forward
if you could sit the desk in the middle
there um and give your presentation and
stay for questions afterwards once you
are done you will see there is a hand
gel and also some sanitizing wipes if
you could please give the desk a quick
wipe down the same with the microphone
as well and then sanitize your hands i
would be grateful there's a bin just to
the right of that desk where you can
stick any of the uh the bits and pieces
um i will dive into some introductions
then so to my far right we have liz
dewarska from committee services to our
immediate right we have ross chambers
who is our solicitor and in no
particular order our planners are amy
flute aaron weatherston and stuart
flaherty and to my immediate left we
have tracy humphries who's our planning
manager and tracy i believe you have a
statement to make
thank you chairman yes uh just to advise
that the planning manager's role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking thank
you thank you very much indeed let's
dive into the meeting proper so first of
all apologies for absence please thank
you chairman we have apologies from
councillors adam curtis tonight
thank you very much and disclosures of
interest members do you have any
disclosures you'd like to make
no i have one um
on application twenty one zero one nine
two five full the old rick ridge road uh
the old vicarage smithfield road um the
applicant is known to me by virtue of an
as an old playing member of cleveland
rugby club we haven't spoken to each
other for crumbs it must be 10 years or
more so i'm here with an open mind um on
that item i just wanted to make that
known
minutes members are you happy and
content with the minutes as presented so
i can sign them and afterwards quick
show of hours i've got nods everywhere
so i think that's unanimous marvelous
thank you very much let's dive into our
first application then which is
application number 21 0 1 1 3 0 f ul
that's western house in welford on aven
our presenting officers amy
thank you chairman
the application site edge black is an
existing dwelling in welford which is
recognized as a non-designated heritage
asset the site is accessed of milcot
road to the south the application site
is within welford's um identified
built-up area boundary the site is bound
by residential properties to the west
north and east planning permission is
sought to retain and alter the existing
dwelling and build four dwellings within
the grounds with associated access and
works
a scheme for seven dwellings which
included the total demolition of western
house has previously been refused the
proposed layouts and visuals for the
proposal that was refused can now be
seen
western house plot free will be retained
as the central dwelling to the site to
facilitate the development partial
demolition of western house will take
place four dwellings and associated
carports are proposed to be sited within
the grounds of western house
plots one and five will front millcut
road and the access road that serves the
site the dwellings will be one and a
half story l-shaped in design
plot three illustrates western house in
the form that it is to be retained
plot 2 will be to the north west of
western house and plot 4 will be to the
north east of western house both are one
and a half story all dwellings will use
facing materials such as brick tile
hanging and tiles to complement western
house
site sections can now be seen which
demonstrate the proposed dwelling sorry
which demonstrate that the proposed
dwellings are subservient to western
house
the scheme will be landscaped retaining
existing mature hedgerows to the north
east and west which acts as existing
boundary features between the site and
neighboring properties the existing
southern hedgerow will be retained
albeit where the new access is proposed
existing trees will also be removed to
facilitate the access with replanting
within the site
so this these images are of western
house
the modern single story additions to the
east which link round to the garage to
the north are to be demolished
and the main part of western house will
be retained
the top image is taken um
looking at the site's eastern boundary
and the site's relationship with number
two milpat road
the bottom bottom image is looking back
towards western house where the grounds
of the dwelling can be seen as can the
site's southern boundary
looking in a southwesterly direction
from western house the site's western
boundary can be seen which is a mix of
existing fencing and mature hedgerow
the visibility display can now be seen
in the approximate position of the new
access looking in a westerly direction
along mielco road towards long marston
road and an easterly direction along
milkup road
these images show views of the site when
traveling west along milcook road the
relationship with the site and milk up
close can be seen the site's southern
boundary can be seen which is a mix of
mature hedging and close boarded fencing
and this image shows the relationship of
this site with millcote to the
east of western house
chairman the proposal will retain a
non-designated heritage asset it is not
considered that the proposal will result
in
unacceptable harm to the landscape
neighbouring immunity highways or flood
risk chairman the recommendation is to
grant the application subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed within
the committee report please also note
some updates to the
report on the update sheet thank you amy
thank you very much we will call on our
first speaker who is counselor jamie
hockaday sorry i hope i got that right
good evening and welcome
so you'll have three minutes and i'll
give you a 30 second warning uh before
the end whenever you're ready if you
want to press the middle button on the
microphone feel free to start
if i can't have the 30 seconds please
i'll i i won't be more in three minutes
and i would rather not be off put if
that's all right so thank you
this site has a planning history of
either withdrawn or refused planning
permissions
there are 32 letters of objections the
parish council object the ward member
objects
i'd like to discuss the most recent
reasons for refusal
and why they remain relevant in
determining this application
reason one
the local authority designated the
building as a non-heritage asset
cs8 core strategy
priority will be given to protecting and
enhancing non-designated
assets
he4
development will be supported if it
protects or enhances the heritage assets
how can demolition of 50 of the
footprint of the building protect or
enhance the asset and therefore be
policy compliant the most recent
planning refusal also considered public
benefits and concluded in planning
balance was contrary to the core
strategy and the neighborhood plan
i'd now like to focus on why there is no
need or public benefit
cs16 proposed 84 new homes to welford
202 have been approved
sdc has an 8.42 year land supply
the sap ranks welford as a tier vii
settlement
the may 2019 welfare donating housing
needs survey concludes that two and
three-bedroom homes and bungalows are
required
i'd also point out that contrary to the
officer report
the housing needs survey is the most
up-to-date
policy matter it is not even referred to
in the officers report
not hlu1 has referred to
reasons two and three of the previous
refusal recited the number of houses
style size scale massing
for projecting nature outside the
building line and the loss of the front
boundary hedges being contrary to policy
cs5 cs-9 as-10 hlu5 and hlu6 this
application is only for two less houses
than previously 60 of that mature front
hedges to be removed and the front
boundary and the dwellings continue to
breach the boundary line the policy
reasons remain the refusal
finally i'd like to raise a concern over
highway safety the proposal is so over
developed it is not possible to
accommodate a turning refuse vehicle on
site instead it is reliant on the refuge
stop stopping on milcope road to empty
the bins this is the veil of eastern
trunk route warrior county council have
not commented on this matter because bin
strategy is a matter for sdc and
therefore this important matter has been
overlooked for all these reasons
i would encourage you please to vote
against and refuse this application
thank you very much
good spot on thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for our
counsellor
cancer mills
thank you very much um did you did you
say that 50 of the
main buildings being taken away
demolished it
i did 50 of the building by floor area
ah right the footprint of the building
is being demolished this is a heritage
asset
and heritage assets are about the scale
of the whole they're not about removal
of individual parts
both sdc's policy
and welfare don't neighbor welford and
abraham plan policy talk to the about
the heritage asset about protection of
the whole they do not talk about
let's cherry pick which parts we may
choose to
remove and of course
you might refer to which bits have been
being removed this is a grand building
and grand status and with grand
buildings you get garages you get
ancillary facilities and those are
proposed to be removed and they all
contribute to the heritage asset
thank you very much thank you that's a
crime
uh hello cancel how today i just got
across can they um yeah you mentioned
the need identified for two and three
bedrooms and i slightly confused was it
the neighborhood plant or the housing
survey or the house employer i didn't
quite catch that bit sorry okay so it's
the housing
it's called the welford on haven housing
needs survey
it's a published document it's an
adopted document
and
sadly it is not referred to at all in
the offices report
instead the officer
refers to hlu1
which is
outdated
because that is the plan policy rather
than the up-to-date survey which has
been undertaken in 2019
do another one cancer cramp
just about to ask and then counselor day
so 2019 so that was a perfect
number there's any other questions
no in that case counselor thank you very
much for your time
thank you
perfect thank you very much
okay if we can call forward our next
speaker on this item who is amanda
stobbs on behalf of the applicant
good evening and welcome
so in the same way you'll have three
minutes i will give you 30 second one
before your time is up and if you could
say c different questions afterwards
otherwise whenever you're ready feel
free to start
thank you chairman councillors gravada
properties limited are a privately owned
residential development company based in
stratford-upon-avon
they have a proven track record of
delivering quality homes employing local
trades and services throughout wales or
the west midlands
grave properties specialise in smaller
scale developments using local
architects to create bespoke designs
that reflect the surrounding context and
are environmentally sustainable they
take great pride in their developments
they have engaged with the council at
pre-application stage and throughout the
determination period and they have also
sought to engage with parish council and
have endeavoured to address the concerns
raised
key responses include the reduced scale
of development the retention of the
original elements of the 1930s western
house protecting the elements of the
ndha
using the style and materials of that
building for the proposed new houses and
they're being subservient to western
house as well as the retention of the
frontage hedgerow all important features
raised
as set out in your office's report the
development is acceptable in principle
would successfully integrate into the
locality and deserve an appropriate
scale density and design meeting the
relevant design standards
there are no objections from the
highways authority
environmental health county ecology
fire and rescue service and seven trent
water and your officers report confirms
the proposals are acceptable in respect
of residential amenity housing mix
providing two flexible two strokes three
bedrooms and a four bedroomed houses
acceptable in flood risk and the natural
environment your officer concluded that
the proposed development accords with
both the district and neighborhood
development plans and recommended his
granted approval and we support this
conclusion thank you for listening
thank you very much well within your
three minutes members do we have any
questions for our applicant please
counseling servant
you say um
these buildings are small scale how many
bedrooms are there
to the two properties at the front are
flexible two to three bedrooms
properties and the remaining three or
four beds
okay thank you
any other questions members
no in that case thank you very much for
your time
thank you
while you go through the sanitization
process i will call forward our next
speaker who is counselor perti geller
good evening councillor
i think you know the drill by now so
you'll have five minutes i'll give you a
30 second warning towards the end and
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start
thank you
and good evening so the welford
neighborhood development development
plan policy about heritage he4 states
development proposals should announce
the significance of heritage assets
and these ecoscore strategy csa
the plan showed a large portion of the
building will be demolished including
the original garage building this will
affect the integrity of western house
therefore these proposals still
negatively impact on our local built
heritage with resulting harm to a
non-designated heritage asset western
house should be safeguarded as a whole
the recent house in its survey adopted
by the parish council in may 2019
specified that the village needs two to
three bedroom houses uh in particular
bungalows the type of proposed houses in
this application does not meet housing
needs of the village
the proposals which have ignored the
housing needs survey therefore go
against the mppf which empowers local
communities to shape development in
their own areas
further the officer herself raises
concerns in a report about housing
numbers and a further burden on the
settlement
at a rate of change which is
unsustainable the officer then refers to
policy hlu1 which supports most
small-scale development in the village
but this small-scale development
um
is with specific regard to the role of
category two local service villages in
the core strategy and any number of
homes proposed must be consistent with
the overall scale of development in the
village in the case of welford donavon
the scale of development is 84 houses
according to policies cs16 and cs15
while for donavon has seen an increase
in development 202 new houses approved
as per october this year
and has been placed in tier 7 for
release of sites in the site allocation
plan
at the last planning committee meeting
when i was present the committee this
committee was told by policy officers
that the sap did carry material planning
considerations so you will now need to
consider the tier allocation and look at
the numbers and whether these houses are
of any public benefit here you also need
to take into consideration as any
inspector would
the stratfor district council has now a
solid land supply in excess of eight
years
the core strategy supports locating
development in a manner which minimizes
the need to travel and encourages other
forms of sustainable transport
and this is echoed in policy hlu1 of the
ndp the development does not promote
sustainable transport because of its
edge location the footpath on the milcot
road is less than 1.5 meters wide at
some points and therefore is currently
dangerous for parents children and
wheelchair users to work safely to the
facilities there is no safe pedestrian
crossing on the long marston road where
we have continued speed in traffic and
the long marston road footpath is in
dangerous condition in fact on the 17th
of september warrior county council came
to inspect the longmarson footpath with
our county councillor and agreed that
this needed work the bus in the village
is every two hours and only covers one
particular route the bus time tables
will not suit the needs of commuters the
use of car will therefore be encouraged
i'm very concerned that no safety audit
has been undertaken milcot road is part
of the velovision trunk route as a trunk
route it gets traffic from the diverted
agvs and lgbs
further there is no mention of a waste
collection strategy in the report on the
officer report in the seventh paragraph
there is a following statement i also
noted that there will be a bing
collection point set back from the
highways which appears to accord with
part
p of the spd either the proposal does
meet the requirements or it doesn't
the proposal is also contrary to
neighbor development plan hl u6
development at the village edge the
boundary addison to the highway is
currently mature edge row and this is
what you can see when traveling into the
village but the majority of these will
be removed for the access the removal of
the edge row is against ndp policy and
represents a loss of biodiversity the
proposals do not create a sensitive
transition from countryside to village
but rather will contribute to its
sprawling
finally the proposed lighting scheme
does not accord with the dark sky
policies of the ndp our policies made
and therefore carries weight but we feel
the known has been given
30 seconds
on balance there is more than sufficient
planning evidence to refuse the
application there are no public benefits
and therefore i urge you counselor to
reject it
thank you passed gala thank you very
much members do we have any questions
for our counsellor please
no
okay in that case council best guess
thank you very much for your time input
this evening
right we will move then two points for
clarification with our officers would
anyone like to kick us off councillor
dixon
thank you chairman
uh amy um we've just heard that the
significant amount of hedge will have to
be removed in order to facilitate the
access would you like to comment on that
please i'm assuming that western house
currently has an access from that road
yep so if you have a look at this photo
here the existing access is
approximately um where my arrow is shown
um
[Music]
if i go to the proposed landscape plan
and let me see if i can zoom in
so
um
this area here indicates the existing
it is to be retained and will be trimmed
um
[Music]
there is then obviously a gap which is
the existing access so obviously it's
not covered by hedgerow then to
facilitate the access
i was just about to ask you exactly that
um i can't see your cursor on there i'm
afraid because
can we see it now
yeah
okay so and this is existing hedgerow
which um is to be um
retained and then obviously there's a
gap where the existing access is um in
order to facilitate the new access some
hedgerows to be removed
um and then
we then obviously the exist um
we then get to the existing hedgerow
which is to be retained this area here
is currently um a close boarded fence
which i can um show you the image of um
now and it's in um proposed to enhance
that area by having um
a hedgerow um which you will be able to
obviously um see from the street scene
so if i just come back out now i'll show
you
the existing
so this is um the part which i was
referring to which is close boarded
fence at the moment
and then
the hedgerow then obviously starts you
need to put your cursor oh sorry
so obviously the existing hedgerow here
and then bear with me i have to come
back to this screen
and then we've got the
area where the existing um close board
defense is which then
um
enters into the hedgerow which you can
then see in the distance here
could you turn your mic turn your
microphone please and there's a planting
plan for as it were hiding that fence or
parts of it at least so this fence is to
be removed and if i go back to the
landscaping scheme
so we're uh
we're potentially increasing the hedge
but simply moving it from one place to
another
um
so obviously there's no hedgerow there
at the moment um and there will be some
some planting
can i ask you not to shout out please
that we are trying to conduct business
here
if i go to the um i've got the landscape
scheme which i can show in full
sorry i'm just stop sharing a moment
okay
here we go
yeah
let me see if i can
show it this way
here we go sorry about that i was just
trying to find the landscaping plan
which has the key on
um so i can be more specific
um
so in this eastern corner
um so the area which is close boarded
fence at the moment will become um
proposed estate railings which will then
have um
native hedging planted behind it
thank you amy that's okay
thank you very much councillor crump
next please
all right a couple of things um
mr chairman thank you um
first the on page 21 the county council
have
got seven conditions um
one of which is the footway crossing
um it'd be interesting to see where the
footweight crossing
is considering um
it's it's a main road i think was the
trunk road i can't remember the right
phrase this will be interesting to see
where that is and how that's been
assessed from a from a road safety point
of view
okay
did you have a second as well you can
give this yeah the second one relates
obviously
whether it's now or when we when we
actually go into the divide it's about
hard and soft landscaping
um
it was raised and scooting this morning
which i will have to be on again um
where sometimes hard and soft
landscaping in other schemes not
necessarily on on from planning um
the uh the hard and soft lunch game
doesn't work very well or dies so is
this is there something in our agreement
with them that they they maintain them
until i matured and
you know have sufficient water and
whatever
um
okay we will ask that um and i'm sure we
can always add something to a condition
if need to be
i can answer that as we wait chairman if
i'm just uh searching for the right
photo to show you where the footwear
crossing is but yes just in terms of
landscape replacement we do have um
standard conditions which would cover
not only the installation of the
landscaping but also its maintenance for
a certain time period and then its
replacement if it were to die um
obviously yes we can double check the
precise wordings of the conditions but
it would be quite normal to have that
you know replacement in the event of it
uh not surviving a bad weather event for
example
just to add i think the standard is
within five years so there's a five year
time frame and so in answer to your
question about the footway so um
say this is um
the junction of long marston road with
milcoat road and the application site is
off milcut road so this is the footway
which comes down along um milcoat road
onto long marston road and then we go on
to the um
so this view is
as you are walking down the bottom
picture sorry is as you're walking down
milcoat road you get to long marston
road the crossing point which then takes
you
up along the village
okay council jennings please
thank you chairman uh amy um on the
house saying someone on the original
house it looks like some of it's sort of
quite modern it's could you just point
out on the map
what is the original and
and the bit which looked demolished
looks quite modern compared to the
original
okay so
the area i have got a plan which i can
show you um which shows the extent of
the demolition but i will um just talk
through these images first so we've got
the um side um
elements which is the conservatory and
um
the conservatory and um
the parts which are attached and the
planning permission for those was
granted in the 90s
i believe um it was
19 um so 1995.
um
and then
they link round then to the garage which
is to the rear which is believed to date
to the time of the house
and
originally the garage would have been
detached but because of the extensions
it's now linked to
and i can show you a plan which shows
the extent of the demolition
so this shows the extent of the
demolition
and that's the areas in red is the parts
to be demolished just for clarity
if i might if you've got a follow-up
if i if i may then follow on from that
so obviously we've heard from both
parish council and ward member of the
scale that the suggestion is 50 of the
heritage heritage asset has been
demolished um they also refer to our
policies and their own policies to
protect the heritage assets what's our
justification for removing such a
substantial amount of the building
so
if you bear with me one moment while i
just find um the policy
okay
so
in relation to um non-designated
heritage assets policy cs8 states for
non-designated heritage assets proposals
will be assessed having regard to the
scale of any harm or loss and the
significance of the heritage asset
so as offices now
the main part of western house is to be
retained the areas to be demolished um
in in my view are obviously the elements
which are newer editions
i appreciate and understand that the
garage um
part to be demolished is isn't new it
does date back to um it would appear the
the original dwelling however
given
where it's cited um and um given
what it is um in my view i don't feel
that that
is is as significant as what
the main house is so the proposal is
retaining the significant element of the
house which obviously has the
architectural features
it has um the
the the appreciation with the landscape
um
and also it retains the elements which
um have been referred to in the past
with the links to the community as well
okay thank you very much members do we
have any other questions for officers
before we move into the debate
no in that case let's move into debate
who would like to kick us off
councillor jennings please
this is a this is an interesting one i
know
i look at it and my thoughts at the
moment are
cs15 allows small-scale development and
windfall development within the built-up
area boundary
and as such the principle of housing is
acceptable
um with regards to core strategy
policies as10 cs15
ndp policy hlu1
and this is a lot better application
than the previous one it retains the
original building
um
it looks like there's obviously been an
extensive consultation
run
with this i mean i
i like the look of the development
um i
i'm i'm
very much leaning towards uh
backing up the planning office's
um recommendation of granting
okay thank you is that a proposal or is
it just a leaning two and you'll wait to
hear what everyone wants to say okay
okay listen to everyone
okay who would like to go next
council mills
thanks mr chairman um
i've got a couple of concerns one one is
the the heritage asset um
aspect and also on page 22 in the last
paragraph
um the office is saying i'm concerned
that the proposed development would take
the settlement further above the overall
scale of development identified in the
course tragedy for the whole planned
period causing a further burden on
existing limited services um
according to a net neighborhood
development plan they i
reached their quote aren't they at
welford so i've got
concerns about it um
at that moment i'm
i'm murraying and not backing the i'm
not going with the officer's
recommendation but i'll listen to hear
what other people say thank you mr
chairman
i've got councillor dixon next please
thank you chairman um i'm in the camp of
of grant actually um essentially
i don't think we could i think we would
lose an appeal if it weren't that far um
in respect of numbers of
built in the in the locality because
it's a
small-scale infill site within built-up
area boundary essentially
um now obviously we did hear from the
from the parish council uh along the
lines that
this is only two less than the previous
one but obviously it is a reduction from
the previous one this one does retain a
property which is
described as grandia whether or not uh
it is georgian but certainly it is a a
balanced facade as the main dwelling and
it looks an attractive feature from that
point of view and from the report and
even from the from the photographs i
don't think there's much image of that
from the street scene to start with
whereas this will actually i think open
it up
and actually present it more more
betterly or to a better effect
essentially
the loss of the conservatory in the
1990s extension i i don't see as being a
material impact at all so essentially i
will propose that we follow the
officer's recommendation congrats
thank you very much councillor dixon and
for introducing us to more betterly
which is a new phrase i've never heard
before
council hench the seraphim no i do have
concerns this is not small scale
these aren't small houses
welford's um
survey requires two bedroom houses more
and i think
committee should take more into the
count if there's a number of objections
from residents
parish and ward member
that should weigh heavy they live there
[Music]
what the need is for smaller houses
that's the survey
um
and to me
these aren't small houses
thank you
thank you very much cancer crump
thank you mr chairman um
whilst it might be better in terms of
numbers it doesn't mean to say it's
necessarily right
um
so i've got concerns about this one um
significant local opposition to this
i've looked through a report to see if
there's any body support in it and i
can't see any support
from the local neighborhood i might be
wrong and but from what i can say i
can't see anything there
um significant
objections to this from
um
the parish council the ward member and i
think it said 22
people objected um no and instantly no
support
um
obviously it's contrary to the
neighborhood plan
and i'll get this right hopefully the
wilford and i even housing needs survey
so i apologize if i've got the wrong one
which was only made in 2019
um which predominantly wanted two and
three bedroom houses which this doesn't
necessarily
uh
attribute to you know
a line too sorry
um
again
does it protect uh the non-designated
heritage asset i don't think it does
just enhance the non-designated heritage
i don't think it does and knocking down
the original garage whilst um you know
it's a matter of playing balance and
judgment and again if it's been there
since
the 1930s and again i might be slightly
poetic licensed there but been there for
a good while um i don't think it's quite
right so
i'm i'm not proposed to i'm not
proposing to support the officer's
recommendation on this one thank you
are you proposing to refuse
yeah i'll go with the proposal to to
refuse okay so you're proposing to
refuse
while we continue the debate if you come
up with your reasons your planning
reasons for refusal yeah i'd be very
helpful
county planning next please
i'm sort of tending to support what
counselor crump and case the mills are
saying i don't like the amount of
demolition that this thing's
going to take place
i think that it damages what's listed as
a heritage asset because that particular
garage extension although there's a
modern link
that was part of the original building
um and again we're
we're growing villages by stealth by
small
uh small
developments
small scale developments as they've been
described um and it's filling in every
bit of green space within these villages
and whatever and although this is right
on the end i still i'm not comfortable
with the way it's done but like i said
the biggest thing for me
is uh we talk about you know preserving
heritage assets well the heritage asset
is the house with that garage on it and
if you take it down all you're left with
is a square fairly soulless looking box
although it's a 1930 first
soulless looking box and so i wouldn't
be supporting it okay thank you very
much council candle next please oh god
okay i'm really i'm going backwards and
forwards on this one i'm really
struggling with it i'm listening to the
arguments and i think council dixon
makes a very good argument about whether
or not
this would um
go through an appeal
i think we might struggle with the
appeal so i look to the arguments from
councillor crump and councillor fleming
and i'm not finding them to be strong
enough this is my concern so i'm not
finding the arguments to reject this
strong
strong enough
affecting the heritage asset the
majority of the building is remaining
we're talking about effectively the loss
of a garage
i don't i just don't find that to be
strong enough grounds to go against the
officer's recommendation
in terms of the housing need in the area
i think the key wording and i think
council dixon said it earlier is to do
with
whether or not
this is small scale
when we talk about small scale we don't
necessarily mean size and houses we talk
about the number of houses so this is
right as far as i can see a small set
scale development
that being the case although i really i
want to be clear about this i do not
like it very much but i can't find
strong enough planning reasons to go
against it
so for that reason with a very heavy
heart i will second the recommendation
to grant
thank you very much council foreman
please
thank you i'm also struggling with this
one to be quite honest i'm i'm still i
would be interested to hear what
councillor trump's um objections are
going to be based on
um
i think the the building
we are keeping the majority of it but we
are losing the garage which actually is
part of the 1930s so i'm not sure
that the houses that around it we are
making it a better situation than it is
now so i am struggling with this one at
the moment still
thank you
cancer dixon
thank you chairman i think uh councillor
herrera peter henshaw centerfriend
mentioned the fact that the ndp was
seeking two and three-bedroomed
properties and i think when we heard
from the agent they said that the two at
the facing on the road were two
three-bedroom properties can we ask the
officer amy to uh because obviously we
haven't had floor plans specifically are
we talking about potentially two and
three bedroom properties here or be it
the ones at the back may be larger
so this is the floor plan for um plots
one and five which are at the frontage
they show a bedroom at ground floor
level a bedroom up for first floor level
and then a study so the study may be
used as a bedroom
two with a study three so two free
okay do we have anyone else that would
like to contribute to the debate before
i chuck my two pennies worth in
i'm sorry we can't take uh questions or
comments from the floor i said at the
start this is a meeting in public not a
public meeting so only registered people
can speak
so unless anyone else has anything they
would like to contribute to the debate i
will chuck in now
um
like most of you i think i've been doing
in throwing uh councillor dixon made the
point earlier on um and i'm in agreement
with this that actually the opening up
of the fencing the front and the way the
development has been presented to us i
think presents western house in a much
better light than it does in its current
form
that being said
i also agree with cancer kendall sorry
not cancer kendall was counselor mills
crump i think most of you really
the loss of the garage does frustrate me
somewhat i have no problem with the 95
extension or any frankly any of the
extensions that have happened since the
original build where i do have some
concern is over the loss of that garage
it's a question for me of weighing up
the benefit of opening up and presenting
the house
the western house um
for the public to see versus the loss of
that garage garage is behind the house
so it doesn't really present that in any
greater light anyway so for me it's it's
i'm wrestling with that um i can see
both sides of the arguments what i want
to do now we obviously have a proposal
to grant that has been seconded we have
had a proposal to refuse
um i'm going to seek
the reasons for refusal for councillor
crumps to see if that will help tease
out some more thoughts from members and
we also need that to be seconded should
we have to go to that
that point so council crump do you want
to
teasing out that's a good phrase
i know i can be a bit of a tease and
almost this kid is more betterly yes
definitely
um yes so i think this potentially
uh it doesn't protect a non-designated
heritage which is contrary to i believe
to csi the development again doesn't
enhance a non-designated heritage acid
um
housing need
is
why the welfare now haven housing needs
survey and i think it's ndp policy
hlu4
identifies two and three bedrooms and
this
only potentially gives fifty percent of
two and three bedrooms uh which i don't
think and bearing in mind the amount of
houses wildford has taken which is
significantly over
the um the number i think
i don't know exactly but i i believe the
parish council mentioned 202 compared to
84. and i'm sure because i'm close
enough i might throw something up if
i've got the wrong numbers we've got an
four two years housing none supply and
it's a tier seven and yes uh ns
emerging strategy emerging numbers i got
sap i said i couldn't think of it i was
thinking s something s p but yes up um
so yeah long day
again the significant local opposition
to this
and whilst it's small scale
um we've
seen that walford
has had a drip feed in small numbers
that have gradually increased the amount
of houses
so we haven't all of a sudden had 40
houses in one go we might have had 10
knots of four again
that's an example not starting they have
but i'm trying to illustrate the point
there
so that's that's basically my objection
to this um
and the only thing i would say
that
i don't think we should bear in mind
i think we have reasonably strong
reasons here for refusal and whether
we lose it at appeal
shouldn't be part of the debate
so that's that's just my final point
okay thank you council crumb just to sum
that up if i can um the three reasons
for refusal i think i picked out there
so the heritage in the first instance uh
so not protecting uh the uh the heritage
asset on london against the terrorist
asset um
housing need
there's reason two um uh which
contravenes uh hl u4 i think uh is the
policy and then the housing numbers so
cs16 and the uh the numbers taken by
welford is that right um okay
personally i'm uncomfortable with the
last one we have tested that out appeal
um but i understand that you you know
you want to put that reasoning forward
and it can always be tested again um
i'm going to speak i'm going to turn to
my planning manager now just to give us
their take i'm i'm particularly
concerned about the housing need bit but
if you give us your
understanding of what's been said and
that'll be helpful
thank you chairman yes it's been a good
debate and i think members have
summarized the pros and cons with the
scheme quite well and in fairness we we
have set out what we feel to be a
balanced report and acknowledged areas
where we feel that assessment is indeed
on balance
nevertheless we do feel fundamentally
that this scheme is a significant
improvement on the uh the previous
scheme that saw the complete demolition
of western house
um as a non-designated heritage asset it
means it doesn't benefit from statutory
protection it's not a listed building
and it's not within a conservation area
um officers are strongly of the view
that loss of the garage alone is not
enough
in our view
to to warrant refusal of the scheme on
on non-designated heritage asset grounds
uh we do feel that it's it's a
significant improvement having the the
bulk of the original dwelling retained
as part of the scheme and accordingly
the total numbers of additional
dwellings are reduced accordingly and
you've been able to see in in sort of
the street scene impressions that that
have been provided how they the lower
profile of the frontage units we feel
gives a much more
appreciable transition to the
development on the edge of the built up
area boundary
now i mentioned built up area boundary
because that's also obviously identified
in the ndp the site does fall within the
buab boundary and it's clear that uh
provided that scheme is felt to be
small-scale infill that the principle of
residential development is acceptable in
buobs in those circumstances and we do
feel that scheme of uh of four units
which we have in front of us does make
that that definition of small scale
infill
furthermore we put some explanatory
texts into the report um which we'd uh
taken from policy um
sorry hlu1 which is
in the ndp where it acknowledged that
further development during the planned
period should therefore take the form of
small-scale windfall development on
infill and redevelopment sites within
the village boundary
so we do feel that the ndp itself is the
up-to-date local policy we do feel that
scheme um
supports that a lot more than uh than it
doesn't in terms of housing mix um we do
feel that
four dwellings two of them in particular
fall within the categories of uh of
bedroom numbers that uh that have been
spoken about and when amy showed us the
um
uh the floor plans we were able to see
that the study is is
notably smaller than the two main
bedrooms
so putting those issues together and
incidentally councillor crump also did
mention the sap i would caution members
that sapp hasn't been through
examination yet it's therefore not a
weighty document that we can base um
planning management decisions on so if
you were minded to refuse it we wouldn't
be recommending to members that they
quoted the sap as uh as a
sort of an established policy of the
council at this stage
so specifically on the three reasons
that have been given
you're uncomfortable with the housing
numbers you're satisfied it sounds to me
that with the um uh the housing needs
survey by virtue of the two
two beds at the front so the only
realistically the only one you're really
comfortable with is the heritage one
although you've given off to your reason
of being non-designated and hasn't got
statutory um
protection is that a fair assessment
i think that's the first summary
chairman although as officers you will
see from our recommendation we don't
feel in non-designated heritage terms
that the loss of the garage is enough to
withstand a reason for refusal members
we accept can take a different view if
you wish council crump would you like to
i think you put your hand up you you'd
like to say something else yeah i think
it's just the fact that
the ndp obviously the parish council are
heavily involved and it was mentioned
the small scale and one four sites etc
rather than any other developments
and they've come and spoken really
strongly against this side because they
don't feel it meets their ndp
in
as far as i concerned so i would take
the contrary view that
that the parish council don't feel that
fits into their ndp so therefore it's
contrary to the to them
and obviously that
they wrote it all or
significantly okay
so you okay so just so we're clear your
proposal still stands for the three
reasons you've given the heritage the
housing needs and the general housing
numbers supported by the
relevant policies within both our course
ratchet and the neighborhood development
plan i'm going to ask for a second uh
for that um of crumbs four hands went
flying forward then
uh given cancer and stereophone has got
his purple what's it i sure i shall put
his name on it um so we have that second
is okay we do now need to move into uh a
vote so um our first proposal was to
grant in line with officer
recommendation uh that was put by
councillor dixon supported by councillor
kendall could i please have a show of
purple things
for those in favor
okay in that case that proposal fails so
we will move to our second proposal
which is to refuse for the reasons given
could i please have a show of hands for
those in favor of refusal
peter you might want to put your hand up
this is for refusal
we're on the ball today aren't we
and for those against
in that case uh committee therefore
resolves to refuse uh application 21 0 1
1 3 0 ful for the reasons given
thank you very much
let's then move on to our next item
which is application twenty zero two two
two four out that is uh weekly transport
and curtain road in ox hill our
presenting officer is erin williston
we'll just give you a couple of seconds
while you set yourself up aaron and then
whenever you're ready feel free to dive
in
it's all right i'll just do it on this
one
thank you chairman
members members we're back in now so uh
erin is about to begin her presentation
thank you
your application site lies to the
northeast of oxel settlement as
identified by the black dot on this plan
just here ox hill is identified as a
category 4 local service village within
the council's adopted core strategy and
the site lies beyond the draft build
period boundary for this settlement by
approximately 215 metres at its closest
point
outline planning permission is sought
for the demolition of the existing
buildings on the site and the erection
of up to 11 open market dwellings and
seven affordable dwellings with all
matters reserved except for access
this slide identifies the application
site outlined in red just here
the site comprises of both agricultural
and previously developed land and has a
site area of approximately 1.1 hectares
the site includes a number of buildings
identified as a to f on the site plan
hard standing areas in greenfield lands
the site joins open countryside to the
north here and to the east
to the west and south of the application
site lie three close neighbours here
here and here
the application site has two vehicular
access points from the clinton road to
the west to the north located about here
and to the south of the application site
just about here
across the road
lies the neighboring ward of eddington
the ward boundary is shown by the pink
dash line on the plan just here
public right-of-way ss-39 is located to
the east of the site and shown by the
green dash line just here on the plan
to the south of the application site the
village conservation area is shown in
pink you can see just here
this slide shows the existing site plan
but the building's identified a to f you
see a b
c d e and f
the two modern buildings are located to
the north of the site brick built
buildings to the west of the site which
are joined a neighboring property you
can see just here the other neighbor is
just located here and within the blue
line
of the application site is enabling
property just located here to the west
of the site
two access points are visible here to
the north and the second access point to
the south of the application site
you'll see a band of mature trees along
the northern part
and the areas of hard standing are shown
here
and here with a bun to the south of the
site located here
field access is located the east of the
site and the site location plan on the
right hand side of this slide shows the
extent of the application site which
extends into the countryside and open
fields along here and to the east of the
site approximately here
this slide shows an aerial image of the
area the site is located close to the
center of the slide just here you see
the tree line to the north of the site
and the access to the country road to
the west just here
the settlement of box hill is visible to
the southwest of the up of the side just
here
and oxfield manor which is a grade two
littered building is located
approximately here to the south of the
application site
this slide shows the illiterate layout
for the developments you can see the
access here from the time to road to the
west of the site with the dwellings
oriented around a main access road with
a cluster of smaller units located to
the east of the application site for
joining the countryside
this slide shows a google image from the
kingdom road looking towards the
application site the arrow shows the
approximate location of the site just
here you can see the tree line to the
north of the site and the existing
buildings which are visible just here
this slide shows a photograph taken from
a field access from the country road
looking towards the application site see
the tree-lined area just here and the
buildings behind
this slide shows two photographs taken
from the kingdom road looking at the
site frontage you can see the northern
access point just here
existing dwelling to be retained within
the blue line of the application site
here and as you pan around to the second
photograph on the slide the other
buildings which are proposed to be
demolished and a southern access point
with the courtyard with the neighboring
properties just here
to the right of the slide
this slide shows several photographs
taken from the east of the application
site just moving across from the top
left
you can see the existing brick-built
building the bun to the south of the
site and the largest building located to
the east of the application site
the top right image is panned around you
can see the tree line just here to the
north of the site
and the area of agricultural land
located to the east
moving down to the bottom left
photograph on this slide is from an area
of hard standing the stable buildings
are located just to the right of the
slide with a brick-built building you
can see just here
and the final photograph on this slide
was taken looking north you can see the
tree line in the background and the two
modern buildings here and here
this light has a number of photographs
within the courtyard area with adjoining
neighboring properties the top left you
see the other side of the brick-built
building
and then top right you can see the
access back towards accounting road the
neighboring property located just to the
left of the photograph here
the next image shown just here you can
see the neighboring property and the
boundary of the site and the final
photograph is taken looking into the
courtyard area with the neighbouring
property you can see just here to the
south of the site and near the
neighboring property just here to the
right of the image
this slide contains a video of the west
of the application site
so it will just load now
so it's panning around you can see the
two modern buildings the tree line to
the north the existing access points to
the counting road the building to be
retained and the brick built building
located just here to the west of the
site
this final photograph was taken from
public right of way ss-39 looking in a
northwestern direction towards the
application site you can see the
neighboring property here brick built
building here the larger one
and the larger eastern building here
with the tree line in the background
the number of updates for this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet and it's recommended
that planning permission be refused for
the reason set out in the officer report
thank you erin thank you very much
indeed okay let's call on our first
speaker for this item who's counselor
derrick harbour
who's chairman of oxfield parish council
good evening and welcome
and once you've got yourself settled
you'll have three minutes i'll give you
30 second warning if you press the
button in the middle of the microphone
it'll go red and you'll be able to speak
otherwise whenever you're set and ready
it's over to you
30 seconds
magic thank you very much indeed members
do we have any questions for our
counsellor
councillor mills thanks
evening derrick
hi um i see on your
uh objections number one it says no
objection principle can you can you
expand on that well he said no
in principle to redevelopment of the
residential site
within the cartilage of the buildings
can you expand on that
well there are buildings there on the
site if those buildings were taken down
and replaced by other buildings on the
ground site yeah people have no
objections
thank you very much thank you
any other questions members
no in that case council harbour thank
you very much for your time and input
this evening
while you're sanitizing our desk for us
uh i will call forward our next speakers
who i've listed here mr and mrs neil and
also sarah cole are we having all three
of you speaking or is just one of you
no problem
you have made it you're here do come on
down
so once you're settled you'll have three
minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning again if you press the red
button the red button the button in the
middle it'll turn red and you'll be able
to speak so whenever you're already do
feel free to start
thank you
as immediate neighbors to the site we do
generally support its redevelopment
however has been expressed by others
including derek a moment ago we do agree
that the scheme proposes the wrong
scheme for a large number of reasons
we're also disappointed at no time have
we been approached to discuss the scheme
or the intentions of the owner it's
disappointing that they do not feel that
communication with us is necessary to
get to this stage
our main concern relates to the fact
that the proposed development greatly
exceeds the boundary of the previously
developed site and extends into the
greenfield agricultural land
it's been suggested that greenfield area
has been used for other purposes i.e
parking that has not been the case
during our seven years of occupying
neighboring property and it's only been
used for grazing for horses and qi
we do not believe the number of units is
tenable for the location of the site
being immediately next to it the village
does not have the infrastructural
facilities to support development of
this size it is also too far from the
center of the village to be feasible
we live next to the site and are
constantly navigating the perils of
existing speeding traffic that ignores
the speed limit signs immediately
outside our house and the site and the
site sits at the brow of the hill and
without considerable traffic calming
measures the number of trips is to
generate in and out of the site would be
extremely hazardous and dangerous
we have grown up children who still feel
unsafe walking the road down into the
village and the suggestion that the site
would be safe for a large number of
families we believe is laughable without
the inclusion of a footpath down into
the village the number of risks this
will impose on people trying to access
the village must be considered too great
the proposed over development of the
site into the field next door also
requires removal of a number of
substantial trees that offer the benefit
of screening us at the top of the hill
as the planning office's recommendation
we'd hope the committee agrees this
scheme is unreasonable and should be
refused but the applicant being
encouraged to submit a scheme that is
more sympathetic
and has the support
via communication of us and the village
that's me
all right as well within your time thank
you very much members do you have any
questions for mr neil please
no
in that case mr nils thank you very much
for your time and contribution this
evening
okay we'll call on our final speaker on
this items cancer fielding cancer
filling you want to make your way
forward
you uh you know the drill you've got
five minutes 30 second warning before
the end use as much as little as that
five minutes as you wish uh whenever
you're ready it's over to you right as
when i get started
um outline planning is your just double
check your microphones on please it is
on yes okay sorry it's black from this
angle thanks
outline planning applications indicate a
possible scheme that could be carried
out on land
most outlines are submitted by a
developer
in this case the lando
landowner has no intention to develop
the site
this is an unbeatable application as it
comprises both brownfield
and greenfield land the
indicative scheme
takes in some of the field that was used
as garden land
this was due to the brownfield land
being used as a lorry depot the family
had to use the field to the north as a
play area for their children and car
parking for lorry drivers
you will see from this still photograph
lorries were parked across the site
could you put the next one on please
still photograph thank you
now
the owner has tried to look for other
uses for the buildings but these are not
suitable due to their size insulation
and asbestos
as10 indicates
in
introduction gives some leeway for
brownfield sites
i will concentrate on the lorry parking
area could you put that one up which
shows
the not the indicative side but the
full side
thank you
um
i was told that the site had been placed
on the brownfield register
no there's a better one which is closer
in thank you
um
and
sorry has been put on the brownfield
register
but missed some years ago if this land
is not developed for residential use
then the only other schemes that could
be considered are light industry or a
drip gypsy and traveler parking area
neither of these two alternatives would
meet with the council's approval and its
proximity to the aonb
consultation was also had with wrcc
sarah brook taylor concerning affordable
social schemes
they were
they were looking at um bringing in
other
villages where they the need for rural
housing was necessary it's believed that
several housing associations were
interested as they met the minimum
number the planning officers produced a
very detailed report
commenting with regards to street
lighting for a pavement that would not
be approved by the village as it's
considered a dark sky village
there's also a footpath in the field
that belongs to the the owner landowner
and it runs down into the village near
the pub this could easily be connected
to the development
as a site slopes to the north
away from the village any excess water
that's not harvested in this development
would run in that direction away from
oxil and other major concerns
that are
that
sorry other major concerns
that have been raised by the highways
would be dealt with at
um
with a proper planning application all
core strategy matters raised will be
subject to a full planning
my main support for this scheme
is the development of the brownfield
land for residential development
if the committee are not happy with the
greenfield land being brought into this
development could they approve the
brownfield land at the hearing other
matters could then be part of the
condition for grant
and i underlined that
a developer
would have the right to put on the site
what was approved by the planning
officers rather than um an indicative
plan that is there
um there are
some other
videos that i've got done i don't know
whether they're
i think you've used one of them or maybe
not which shows the courtyard behind
the house
there again there are concerns about the
nearness of the
indicative scheme too i think it's
robin's nest
that again is part and parcel with a
legal agreement if once the land is sold
and that driveway into that area in the
south side of the site would be closed
off as far as the development was
concerned on the brownfield land
so
there are
issues here but the main thing is that
the brownfield 30 seconds which is what
i've discussed with
uh strategic planning is what i consider
to be
suitable for planning for development
okay thank you very much cancer fielding
i think you said there are some videos
um given we have them and uh aaron has
very kindly brought them up we'll
quickly watch them
okay i think is it just a two
john john sorry i'm going to ask you to
stop speaking now please you have
already exceeded your five minutes
realistically this should have been part
of it
okay those are the three videos we were
asked to look at so members do we have
any questions for cancer filling please
counselor dixon
thank you chairman uh councillor
fielding just a one question um
obviously we understand from your
comments that uh the owners and agent
have been in contact with wrcc do you
know if they actually asked wrcc to
support the application because there's
nothing before as indicating that they
might be
wrcc likes the idea but until such time
as a developer is appointed and buys it
it's up in the air because at the end of
the day it is to develop the developer's
privilege
if he wants to go ahead with what i've
suggested in the indicative
but you didn't seem to support it thank
you
do you have any other questions for
cancer filling
sorry health cancer fleming
um the officer said that uh
the owners has tried to find other uses
for this land before it comes
it be proposed to be developed into
housing how long is that how long has it
been empty
um from the transport yard
i think
from i think at least two to three years
the owners have tried their contacts and
everything else to find people to deal
with it
they've now moved to wellspawn where
they have a big depot
okay unless there are any other
questions for cancer fielding uh we will
say thank you cancer filling for your
contribution this evening and we will
move to points of clarification with our
officers members do we have any points
of clarification
council crump
this is might be a general one as well
so it might be a training point as well
um on the previous application where we
talked about 202 houses against 84 in
the
course structure
on page 42 um as mentioned
about policy cs16 states that in other
all locations approximately 750 homes
shall be provided
101 023 have been provided as of march
2020
the oversupply of development within
rural rails is material which weighs
against the proposal which i've got no
reason to disbelieve no yeah i'm taking
that i'm just how does that compare when
we were talking about the previous ones
are we talking are you do you want
information about the previous
application or do you want information
that's relevant to this one because we
can't revisit it now this is already
done it's it's it's to do with how much
weight we give it
because
in previous i i like to be consistent
and that's the reason it's not criticism
of the previous application it's just
how does it compare when we're told in
one
application
the numbers don't really matter
sort of you might get slightly poetic
license
but then we're saying in this one it
does so i'm just confused of saying i'm
not confused of counting on this
occasion so i i i disagree that we were
told the numbers don't matter on the
previous one um
i'm speaking please don't talk over me
i'll speak i disagree with you what i
will do is i will ask our planning
managers to give their view and try and
answer your question that's always
asking for thank you
thank you chairman yes i'm just looking
at page 42 which is i i think the point
councillor crump's making there where
where it talks about sort of um
in respect to policy cx
uh 16
uh and other rural locations it gives
sort of a a total suggested number of of
dwellings which which might potentially
uh come forward during the planned
period
um
obviously this this i think is different
to the previous case because the
previous case was a site that was within
the built-up area boundary um so i
believe the the data that that came
forward for that was relevant to that
particular village whereas this is this
is a general statement of uh of of what
cs16 is is
um uh talking about for other rural
locations so in essence i don't think
the uh the classification of the two
sites is comparable and therefore the
data is different
that's all i needed for a confused
simple cancer like myself you know it's
uh
explaining the differences that the one
was
specific whereas this is a more general
one so yeah oh yeah i i fully understand
though and thank you for bearing with me
chair thank you council trump
any other points for clarification
members
no let's move into debate who would like
to kick us off council jennings
we have to make a judgment on what's
being put in front of us
um
there are so many objections here's
the scheme isn't ready um
to me it's the wrong scheme for this
plot i'm on i'm happy to go with the
officer's recommendation of reviews on
this i'm assuming that as a proposal
thank you very much councillor kendall
yes thank you um look i think the parish
council said a lot of very sensible
things i've got no objection to
something happening on this site one day
but um right now i think the office has
done an excellent job in coming up with
the problems with the application before
us it's essentially half a job
it's not there yet um i'm happy to
second your recommend your uh proposal
can scandal thank you very much council
mills please thank you chairman i think
it probably said it all for me but um
you know i can't see this is it's
unsustainable though
i know oxford ups hill quite well all it
has is a public good one um
but all the other developments been you
know quite close to the village and i
mean this is out on a limb um
and also you've got this um
this is green field you know which is
part of the application which is
it can't be used so um
i'm in favor of supporting the officer's
recommendation mr chairman thank you
thank you very much cancer crump next
please
yeah i'm sorry i did to go on a site
visit and uh was heckled by a few sheep
but
and i could see has got some merits you
know partial break hill site and
potentially filling some unmet
need for affordable housing um but to be
consistent with the previous application
strong local opposition with the parish
council and the joining parish council
37 objections
there's landscape harm i've got concerns
about the road safety footpaths so
it's not quite right so therefore i will
be voting against this
okay thank you very much council
jennings you put a hand up yeah i just
wanted to add that i'm very much in
favor of doing something with the
existing buildings um but just to
emphasize again it's the wrong scheme
for this plan okay thank you very much
council fleming
taking into consideration what uh
councillor fielding was saying in his
support that uh that something should be
done with the brownfield area the site i
think it needs to come back with a
different application or a different
you know a different uh plan um if they
want to develop that
situation then they should go for that
as a direct application that's you're
absolutely right we can only make a
decision on what's put in front of us
today
um i a couple of people haven't spoken i
will just give you a couple seconds if
you want to put your hand up and speak
counselor foreman
thank you
i would just agree with everything else
that's been said i think this this site
should have a development but not this
one so i would agree with what's already
been said
you don't have to speak but if you'd
like to
[Laughter]
for me
seven reasons for objection we've got
two statutory uh objections those alone
would put me in that camp um but we we
also have the the other seven reasons
for a few so i can see no reason to to
go against that so uh we have a proposal
to refuse in line with software
recommendation it's been seconded let's
move to a vote could have a show of
hands please for those in favor of
refusal
appears to be unanimous um so committee
therefore resolves to refuse application
twenty zero two two two four out uh at
wixley transport in ox hill
marvelous
let's move very quickly on to our next
item
which is application reference
2101925 full there's the old vicarage
instanceville road in barely i presented
officers shirt flairty um stuart as soon
as you've got yourself positioned and
you're comfortable please do feel free
to begin
right
thank you chairman good evening
this proposal is seeking full planning
permission for the erection of four
dwellings and associated works including
proposed highways improvements the
application site is within the build
sprayer boundary of barely indicated by
the black dot on this plan here
this site is washed over by green belt
in addition to being within a designated
arden special landscape area
here we see a plan denoting the location
of the site the red line indicates the
application area
the point of access is achieved here off
ash lane
and is partly within the conservation
area which comes to approximately here
on my if you can see my cursor on the
screen
um the entirety of the built form
proposed i.e the four dwellings uh
reside outside of the conservation area
there is also a grade 2 listed building
poachers cottage which is here
here we have the proposed site layout
plan
in addition to the four dwellings
proposed to be cited here
there are some highway improvements
proposed
namely the aries
shaded in dark gray
a small segment here
a larger segment here and two areas here
and here on the uh junction of ashlane
and smithfield road
here we see the elevational detail um
for the two detached dwellings
that are
sorry biggie pardon here we see the
elevation detail for the two
semi-detached dwellings um these are
bungalows and identical um identicated
indicated as plots two and three uh they
are to be bungalows
uh here we now see uh the elevation of
detail for the two detached dwellings
namely plots one and four which are to
be bookended either side
they are to have two flaws of
accommodation and are the same height as
the bungalows these are proposed to be
four bedroomed
we now have some photos of the site here
we are stood on ash lane looking
westwards towards the point of vehicle
entry
one can see that there is a garage here
and a shed here that are both proposed
to be removed to accommodate this
development
um here we are now moving a little bit
further into the site
um again looking in the same
direction here we are now stood in the
approximate center of the site looking
eastward back towards ashlane
one can see the old vicarage eye the
host dwelling here
finally here we are stood north uh
looking north north eastward towards the
rear of the neighbouring dwellings on
smithsfield road
uh positive and proactive discussions
have taken place between the applicant
consultancies and the district to
attempt to find acceptable solutions for
this site
officers are a view that this proposal
seeks to deliver four family homes of a
type that meets a criteria stipulated in
the local neighbourhood development plan
for a desired mix in what is agreed to
be a sustainable location within the
village
i refer everybody to the update sheet
for a series of updates
um
chairman the recommendation as is partly
reflected in the in the update sheet is
to grant this application subject to
recommended conditions and no of
additional consultation responses being
received to the revised red lion edge
reconciliation exercise which is raising
issues which have not already been
considered in the officer's report
and further for reasons set up pages 69
and 70 of your gender packs thank you
sure thank you very much members the um
the update sheet is quite substantial
have you all had an opportunity to read
it or do you want a quick 30 seconds to
do that now
i'm seeing lots of nodding so let's
crack on um okay um in that case our
first speaker on this item is um
counselor arsene
i hope i pronounced that correctly uh
chairman of billy parish council
welcome and good evening
i think you've probably got a handle on
on how things can proceed you've got
three minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning um and if you can stay seated
for questions afterwards otherwise
whenever you're ready do feel free
thank you chairman and good evening
everyone billy ndp seven years in the
making is nine days old
it's been made
neither our ndp no comments appear to
have been read
committee report ignores that we have
already delivered
seven affordable five market houses on
brownfield sites
plus three infill
we are supporting an outline application
of up to 32 houses and 12 business units
on a brownfield site
and will beat our
core strategy target of 32.
the proposal causes 50
increase in housing 100
in vehicle numbers creating an
everlasting access problem in ash lane
there is loss of amenity to the hosts
nitto field road properties adverse
impact on the openness of the green belt
and surface water flooding wrist
as my slide in slide indicates
the site allocation assessment
done by sdc
identified a true limited infill gap for
two houses between old vicarage and
rivendell with snitter field road access
as shown on the diagram
the pc would support such an application
the proposal does not satisfy known
limited infill definitions of filling a
gap or being in surrounded by built-up
area in the appeal quoted by the case
officer the inspector refused the appeal
by saying
whilst the site adjoins built
development on two of its boundaries it
is also adjoined by
open fields development will not
therefore fill the gap within the
otherwise built up area
the proposed houses are located to the
rear of the existing the development
towards open countryside it would not
result in infilling a gap between
buildings within the village
it is an appropriate development in the
green belt causing substantial harm
no public benefits or exceptional
circumstances are demonstrated to
outweigh that
30 seconds
the parish council
would like it refused thank you chairman
i probably didn't need to give you a
30-second warning sign
thank you very much councillor members
do we have any questions please
council mills
good eat good evening good morning sir
good evening um
it's obviously not in the neighborhood
development plan when was your plan got
adopted
it was 18th of this month oh well done
well done yeah it's not in the end
and tears are right
i can see it i can see it yeah that's
all i need to know thank you very much
thank you
any other questions then numbers
no counselor ms thank you very much for
your time and contributions you can give
just a quick wipeout be appreciated
i thought aaron mez was a mouthful but
uh our next speaker is mr roger
potgeiter potgita is that
correct a second time lucky do come
forward
so again i think you've probably got an
idea of the drill so three minutes i'll
give you a 30 second warning whenever
you're ready if you press the button in
the middle
good man whenever you're ready
good evening everybody
the proposed development
is not the kind of plan that was within
the contemplation of the residents of
berli when they voted to adopt the billy
neighborhood development plan at the
recent referendum
in my view it does not fall in the
definition of small scale we're talking
about four substantial dwellings up to
20 people 13 cars in what is really not
a very large space
i also agree with what's just been said
i don't consider this to amount to
infill
the committee report
um seems to skirt the issue by saying
there's no clear definition of info and
therefore we can define this as info if
we wish however on no interpretation of
that word does this amount to infill you
can see from the pictures that we've
seen already that the site is surrounded
by open countryside on three sides
i would also make the point that there
is no particular demand for this kind of
housing within the village at the moment
there are other schemes underway which
have already been referred to
i don't think the committee report fully
appreciates the impact this will have on
ash lane not only for the residents who
live there but also for the rest of the
village ashlane is a narrow single lane
a picturesque tree-lined avenue which is
used by all the villagers for walking
dogs
ramblers
for all other purposes because it leads
to a public footpath over open
countryside um
it'll during the development phase of
this project it'll be a total no-go area
for the village uh due to the kind of
traffic that'll be present there and
it'll be forever changed in its
characteristic
i want to mention the vineyard
which was the subject of numerous
objections raised by people in the
village
including a scientific report which
referred to the sensitivity of vines to
even subtle changes in soil conditions
the committee report makes no mention
whatsoever or no attempt to deal with
this particular issue
while i consider the vineyard to be a
real asset to the village
the flood risk i think has also been
underestimated you may or may not be
aware that just 18 or 24 months ago the
property to the north west corner of the
site was substantially flooded causing
the residents an 80 something year old
lady who lives there to move out for six
months that is because the proposed
development site slopes both south to
north and east to west downwards causing
natural flow of water down to that
particular corner building on the site
will only exacerbate the problem by
causing increased
water flow to that particular part of
the development
i want to mention privacy and
neighborhood amenity the four properties
on cityfield road which look out over
this
are going to have their privacy affected
i know the report talks about the
distance between housing being between
minimum acceptable standards but it
fails to deal with the fact that the
site is elevated above smithfield road
and those properties will actually be
looking down in the case of rivendale
where i live the house immediately
opposite the ground floor windows will
be at the same level effectively as my
upstairs bedroom windows so i consider
privacy of those residents will be
seriously impacted final point there was
something like 33 objections from people
within the village which is a big number
for a village of that size objections
from the parish council from the council
for the protection of rural england and
as far as i know not a single uh
submission in support
i was just about to ask you to wrap up
but you beat me to it um members do we
have any questions
please
no
i'm going to try it again mr pogbita
thank you very much for your
contribution this evening
okay uh we'll have uh our next speaker
who is our agent and applicant um is are
we going to have both of yourself jane
and
mr white as well or just yourself
just yourself
marvellous okay you absolutely know the
drill you have six minutes uh and i'll
give you 30 second warning over to you
thank you good evening
we would like to start by thanking the
planning officer for his hard work on
the application and comprehensive
committee report
the application seeks permission for
four dwellings a pair of three bed
semi-detached bungalows and two detached
four bed dwellings to create a mixed
development
contrary to what you've heard these do
align with the preferences in the
neighborhood plan and support the
provision of housing for families as
well as providing single-story adaptable
housing that can support people at
different stages of life
the application is a comprehensive
submission accompanied by a landscape
and visual technical note transport
statement including road safety audit
heritage impact assessment ecology
reports archaeological assessment and
tree survey
we recognise that there has been local
objection but those objections have been
addressed by the submission documents
and the officer report before you
the burley neighborhood plan has
recently been made and includes this
site within the village
we've seen the parish council show a
slide this evening with a white
rectangular site
according to the landowner who can't be
here this evening
this is not reflective of his
discussions with the parish council
turning back to policy barley is a
category 4 local service village where
policy cs16 allows for approximately 32
new dwellings
your officer report indicates the most
recently published housing commitments
data of approved dwellings is
considerably less than this
this is in contrast to many other local
service villages including as you have
heard in an earlier application this
evening
the parish council earlier mentioned
their support for a larger development
within their parish
i can't recall whether that's 30 or 32
houses but that is pending consideration
it is not an approved development so it
is not a housing commitment
neighborhood plan policy h1 sets out
that limited infilling and small-scale
development within the belt of arrow
boundary will be supported in principle
subject proposals being in accordance
with core strategy policies and
greenbelt policy
the site is within the built apart
boundary of the neighbourhood plan
the development is small scale in
respect of the number of dwellings being
four and their overall size
infill is not defined in the nppf or
local policy
appeal decisions make clear that infill
in a green belt sense does not need to
be constrained to the filling of a gap
in a built-up frontage
in the context of the site forming part
of the garden of the old vicarage
clearly part of the village and within
the built apparel boundary and the site
being bounded by a vineyard to the west
residential development to the north
north east and east the development does
comprise limited infill in the village
and therefore is a form of development
acceptable in the greenbelt
the site is a large plot within the bull
sparrow boundary and the nppf encourages
making the efficient use of land the
application would do this
the accompanying landscape and visual
technical note by aspect landscape
planning concludes that the proposal
would not harm the special landscape
area would align well with the
prevailing residential character and
that the site is well contained visually
they do not identify harm to the
landscape character of the area
the properties are relatively simple in
form and incorporate architectural
details and finishes that result in an
overall high quality standard of design
the properties in snitterfield road that
they would back onto are bungalows or
dormer chalet-style bungalows
the proposed dwellings have an overall
ridge height of 6.55 metres this would
be of similar scale and in keeping with
the character of the area
separation distances to neighbours set
out in the development requirements
supplementary planning document are
exceeded and this includes taking levels
into account and i note on the update
sheet there is an additional condition
to secure levels details
according to the environment agency maps
the site lies in flood zone 1 and is at
very low risk of surface water flooding
these are the lowest categories of risk
we've submitted some drainage proposals
seven trent have considered these and
raised no objection subject to securing
final detail by condition
no technical consultees have raised
objection to the development and the
proposal is acceptable in terms of
highways impact ecology heritage and
other detailed matters subject to
conditions
thank you for listening i'm happy to
take questions
thank you very much members do we have
any questions for our agent please next
mills
i think hi jane good to see you um jane
you said right at the very beginning of
your presentation uh perhaps i got
confused um
did you say this site is included in the
neighborhood development plan did you or
that good did i get that wrong
so the question that you asked the
parish earlier was the site included in
the neighborhood development plan and i
think they answered no i'm not
sure of the context of the question it's
not an allocated site in the
neighborhood development plan but it's
within the built-up area boundary which
does support limited infilling and
small-scale development so there's no
reason why it's excluded from the
neighborhood development plan as far as
i can tell
i'm just not sure of your terminology of
included
thank you
any other questions members
as you put right counselor mills
any any other questions
no in that case thank you very much for
your time and contribution
okay we'll move to our final speaker on
this item who's cancer shenton
councillor shenson come on down
thank you and again i think you know the
drill five minutes 30 second warning use
as much or a little time as you like
from that five minutes
otherwise it's over to you
sometimes we get feedback
i think it is off at the moment though
okay so looking up for can we have the
first slide up please stuart
so taking a look at this slide
a rural scene with a proposal to build
dwellings on land that is currently
green open and slopes down into arable
land
what's the site uh well within the site
there's a pond where there's great
crested mutes a protected species
and the ecologists can't agree over the
effect of the proposal with the first
ecologist stating that he was originally
minded to refuse whilst the consultant
says that moving it has the capacity to
improve not it will it has this is
uncertainty that affects the life or
death of the newts moving downward on
the land to an award-winning vineyard
vineyard
the change in soil and water conditions
could in all likelihood affect the
quality
taste of the grape and whether the vines
or the vineyard live or die
to the right on that slide
is a local wildlife site again this
could be
severely affected by runoff grey water
human activity as possibly the arable
land as well
rather unhelpfully for the newts and the
surrounding areas the seven trench
solution is soakaways this water could
filter through the strata leach into the
ground and destroy the delicate balance
in this area add to this the total
disregard for the bailey resident's
views and the daily ndp that was made
just nine days ago an extract from the
government website says the following
about ndps and communities they are able
to choose where they want new homes
each of the reports from the various
statutory consorties contain judgments
and conclusions made in isolation of
each other no joined up total view you
do not have to accept them
and there are in my opinion four issues
to consider issue one the national
planning portal
defines infilling in its glossary as the
development of a relatively small gap
between existing buildings i can refer
you to a local case in wilmcote and
inspectorate decisions that support this
view
the proposal does not accord with
existing development and by its nature
therefore does not result in limited
infilling
and is therefore inappropriate
development
inappropriate development by its nature
is harmful to the greenbelt and should
not be approved except in some
exceptions or very special circumstances
there are none
based on the properties that boarded
this application it would mean at least
an 80 increase in dwellings
let's turn to the openness of the green
belt next slide please
you can see from this slide that it
indeed washed over by the green belt
there could be no dispute about this the
land falls away from the proposed site
and dwellings built on it will look
bigger from this view
thereby impacting even more on the
openness next slide please
it's clear that there is nothing there
at the moment
so we can all agree that is open any
development or addition naturally
affects the openness and is by
definition therefore harmful
no question about that it is as simple
as that it harms or it doesn't harm
and the mppf says that substantial
weight should be given to any harm to
the green belt
i emphasize any next slide please
turn into the character and appearance
they would not look like other
properties in the immediate vicinity and
remember the site is partially within
the conservation area the green belt and
the arden special landscape area the
proposal would be harmful to the
appearance and character of the area
directly in conflict with the bili ndp
core strategy and mppf as they say that
planning should take account of the
character of different areas
issue four
are there any special reasons that
totally outweigh all of the above well
the short answer is no
with current applications there will be
up to 40
dwellings potentially being built soon
so the housing need is more than catered
for
none of these applications will damage
delicate eco and biodiversity structures
or conditions as they're all brownfield
sites
unlike this application
it's clear in the minds of myself
residents of the parish council there
are no very special circumstances
necessary to justify the possible
impacts on this area i refuse i urge you
to refuse planning permission based on
the basis of one inappropriate
development in the green belt
two it harms the green belt three it
does not add to the character and
appearance of the area four there are no
special circumstances to justify the
inappropriate and harmful development in
the green belt five the likely damage to
an award-winning vineyard and six the
damage to biodiver biodiversity
eco-structures and the climate by the
destruction by way of the destruction of
trees they're all contrary to our
approved aims agreed in july 19
regarding the climate emergency and
biodiversity as per
paragraph 177 of the mppf
on that point i will end and thank you
for listening to me
good timing thank you very much
councillor shanson members do we have
any questions
to councillor shenton council jennings
please
chairman i just want to get an idea is
this the van is the vineyard uh below or
above the level of the proposal
it's directly below as you look at that
slide at the top you can see the rough
location
of where the four properties will be
the land slopes from there downwards
so any runoff will
ultimately affect those vineyards
delicately
you may or may not be aware but um those
vin those vines particular vines do not
need additional watering as most vines
don't the balance is very delicate
so any runoff of any kind or if they use
soakaways even worse to run off from the
soakaways will affect the soil condition
in that area
any other questions members casa mills
thanks hi yeah um do you know if there
was any consultation from developers
with the parish council and yourself the
consultation
to be honest i've had no
a consultation
with anyone um not from uh sdc not from
the the not from uh the uh the
planners the
consultants i've had no feedback despite
on the website on the portal i actually
stated that i would be quite happy to
take feedback
and discuss the matter nobody came to me
castle crump
um
yeah the vineyard um how many people
employed that do you know please
it's uh generally it's uh i'm aware that
the the owner is here but from memory uh
from what we spoke about this there's
himself and his wife and then he has
seasonal pickers and people to help with
the cultivation they are seasonal by
nature
now just seeing your your report i was
thinking what's this
why do you impact on buddha
diversity in the college and i was
thinking and then i realized it's bio
diversity i think is this a new type of
diversity i don't know about so but you
didn't make me smile on that one okay
thank you unfortunately my typing skills
were not
not that good okay uh members any other
questions at this point
no in that case council trenton thank
you very much your time contribution
thank you very much
let's move ourselves into points of
clarification officers does anyone have
any questions or points of clarification
to our offices
council jennings
is is there anything
in place to protect
the the vineyard
should
the these soak aways
prove proved to be hazardous to them
uh thank you councillor um we do have a
condition secured uh this is following
consultation with seven trent water um
where as just to reiterate what uh mrs
cashmore raised uh seven trent water
were consulted uh they've offered no
objection to these proposed work subject
to a condition for
uh being in accordance with drainage
matters and whatnot
because i just wanted to make sure that
if for instance it then
leached in and killed all the miners
reliable within anybody i i guess the
question is to sort of frame a slightly
different way has there been any
evidence to demonstrate that it could
cause damage to the vineyard
not through our conversation period
no not through consulting uh seven trend
and also through our own uh professional
assessment application
i have a couple of questions if i may
just follow on from council mills
earlier could you for my benefit oh yeah
you've just done it uh bring up a built
up area boundary for me um so clearly it
shows where it is in there um can you
tell me how are there
this site isn't allocated within the ndp
are where are sites allocated on that
map
um i can hopefully answer answer that
question as best i can uh chairman uh
just for everybody's benefit this is the
adopted build spirit boundary as it's
been touched by what's twice this was
formally made
and fully adopted nine days ago
i would remind everybody that in my
committee report that's in your agenda
packs this was post-examination so the
ndp had full weight
in my assessment on the report
this is this application society
question hopefully you can all see my
cursor
um i can confirm that this site
definitely is not an allocated site
with regards to your question as to
where the other allocator sites are
chairman
i'm afraid i can't answer that question
um here and now
but just to reiterate that this is not
an allocated site i understood thank you
very much members any other questions
cancer fleming
with the ink barely dry on their ndp
it's putting it to a test fairly early
on
and when all the villages my village as
well
did these ndps we were told that we
would be given
the opportunity to decide where where
our development goes
um this wasn't discussed prior to the
ndp being made
and
so from my perspective
i don't think that we should we should
give the ndp more weight and
i don't think it's a i don't think it's
infill either because at the end of the
day it's up a track to become infill
it's not it's not a it's not a street
scene where you're putting two houses in
on the street scene it's going through a
narrow gap at the back so i've got two
problems one i don't see is proper
infill and two i think we should give
weight to the ndp
uh council family i think you might have
dialed us into the debate uh
slightly quicker than i wanted you to um
so rather than ask the officers to
respond to that um i think councilman
mills has a question for the officers
and then we will go back to yeah um
actually i was going to put the ndp but
um
the vineyard did did anybody i mean
this is
come to light with me um
as is going on um
has anybody approached the um the
vineyard owner
uh
on the potential
by sound of it um it could wreck their
business if it's um if the flooding came
down so did anybody approach them have a
word with the vineyard
oh no
thank you
but sorry is that part of the year i
mean
it's that's part of the consultation
process and all neighbors would have
been consulted the fact that the owner
of the vineyard is sat directly opposite
me at the moment suggest that he was
approached by sdc's consultation but i
think that's probably the extent of it
um sadly as he was not registered to
speak i can't ask him to come forward
and give us a view anything you want to
add thank you chairman if i may just add
counsellor um we have received
representations from the vineyard
whoever sought to object to his
application so they were invited to
comment and have done so
thankful thank you very much yeah
casagram
yeah hopefully a pretty quick question
that's true um
obviously difference between three trees
and seven trees um obviously got me tree
hat on today can you just explain
they've got no merited non-escape
character is it because they're not very
big or not decent quality can just
explain that comment for me please top
page 69
uh just to be clear then council you're
asking me about the the quality of the
trees that are supposed to be removed is
that correct
so seven instead of three yep and it
says these trees to be able to know
american in landscaped character terms
so you can just get a little bit more
reason for that assessment please of
course um i'm guided by um
my own assessment of this application by
a few different site visits uh i'm also
guided in no no small part by the
submitted tree report and tree survey
that's been submitted in support of this
application
there is a detailed breakdown schedule
at the back of that uh report which
gives a detailed breakdown of the
specimens involved and their quality
there's a categorization of a b and c
and lower
these trees guided by that report were
deemed to be not of a very high quality
as is touched upon in your
agenda pack
thank you
thank you
i can't sense you seraphin
you may
i'm afraid you won't be able to take
lasting the debate though once you've
left the table
i believe that's the rule isn't it
yeah you need to be here for the whole
thing to uh to vote and take part we'll
be quick and you can have an excuse
halfway through or between the next this
one the next one we are going into the
debate now i believe no one else got any
points of clarification let's go into
the debate who's going to kick us off
i'm going to pick on people cancer
kendall oh
i think the entire debate comes down to
whether or not it's inside the built-up
area boundary for me and seeing the map
as we saw a moment ago it is within the
bill to very boundary
i think it is small scale i'm happy to
propose that we grant
i'm going to counter that
and i think it revolves around green
belt policy and whether it can be
considered infill
um it evidently is in the built up area
boundary
does that mean it's in fill
or is the definition of infill uh
between two houses or surrounding all
sides by development that's where i
think this
hinges
i'm struggling to
designate it as infill
but i'm also struggling to see where
else on that map within the built-up
area boundary one could put infill do i
am i you know i suppose this is a
question for members to think about why
your contribution to debate is within
the built up area boundary does that
therefore make it info
um i put that question to you i'll come
back really briefly if that's i think
that does mean that it's infill because
it is within the build of area boundary
and it's a small scale so
for that reason i think that does count
as an infill we've got this my idea in
our minds the infill has to be between
two houses
it doesn't as far as i'm aware if i look
at an officers there it doesn't have to
be between two houses and i think we're
getting on the wrong direction if that
if we're allowing that to color our view
we need to be very clear with what
infill is i think
this although it's not ideal does
present infill but there we go
it's the best bit of debate we've had in
a long time
quite i quite enjoyed that
cancer crumb
a bit about anfield um cancer sheldon
mentioned i think it might have been
wilmcat
but it went to appeal
uh and those discussions of infant i
just wondered whether our legal officer
had got any insight and whether whether
there was any precedent or anything
created by that so sorry russ i'll put
you on on the spot there so i think i
could just refer you to the officers
report really where
he discusses the concept of infill
um
a matter of planning judgment
small-scale development of a plot of
land which fills a gap
within an otherwise built up area as a
definition from a recent appeal decision
page 64.
thank you thank you
i think that answers your question
council grump i'll let you read that
while i call in the other speakers uh
councillor dixon next please thank you
chairman um certainly i can visualize
locations within my ward
where that would be regarded as infill
and has been developed i'm not sure if
they actually went to appeal before they
actually succeeded in getting their
planning permissions etc but certainly
looking at that map i can visualize
exactly a similar location in my ward
but i do recall
possibly there was a case at north end
which went to appeal
where again it was within the built-up
area boundary and it was regarded by the
inspector as infill and it subsequently
went through i think that was one that
might have been refused initially and
went to appeal but i think that's one
that i've seen we've had reference to
previously so
like uh catholic kendall i will be
supporting this application
okay
um i'm going to speak again if i may
before other people um just to say that
so i have similar plots of land in my
ward that would not be classed as infill
but then again they're not within the
built-up area boundary the line is drawn
below
i must say i
have been convinced by councillor
kendall's very passionate element of
debate earlier on um
i'm actually going to second your
proposal
um
and now i've lost track of who's put
their hands up anyone else that wants to
speak can you quickly end up quickly and
i will pull you in individually so
councilman mills first
thank thanks richard um
actually i don't that's a would do and
i've got concerns on this and it's
partially in the conservation area why
shouldn't we be worrying about that
um
i i drove down this ash lane and it is
and i did meet a lady walking a dog um
it's i mean i i found i found difficult
turning around i did eventually go right
down the bottom lane
i've got concerns i know
the um highway is not concerned about uh
access but
this is such a narrow lane i i just
and the construction traffic up there is
is unless you've been up there and had a
look at it
it's unreal it's
the the poachers cottage they could
almost
reach over and touch it you do
development it's such a narrow lane um
and that does have an impact on the
green belt um i've i've got
concerns on this and um
i i've got confused um about this
is it or isn't in the neighborhood
development plan um
according to the um pageant account is
not so i've got concerns over this miss
jim thank you
do you feel free to put a council
proposal in if you wish to i will call
in other speakers before you do that if
you want council former next
thank you um my concern is for the
vineyard is to if we do go ahead and
agree to grant
can we be sure that that's going to be
protected
and the business will survive
council adam thank you for being patient
is that a proposal
a proposal to refuse on the basis that
is not in phil and therefore
inappropriate in the green belt is that
fair yeah
okay thank you counselors hence did you
want to speak
um does anyone else want to speak
council jennings
i mean
it is all the question about infill here
i mean
i i do have concerns for the vineyard
and
it's
i'm trying to find
trying to find
a reason to go against it but it's but
it is within the built up area boundary
to come up with a i haven't i haven't
got a material planning reason to go
against the officer's decision on this i
wish i could
think of one but
i'm struggling on that
so
okay i'm gonna wrap up and we're gonna
move to votes we do have two proposals
and both of which have been technical
too yeah so um
i think
from the sounds of what everyone said
this hinges on whether it is or isn't
infill development ultimately um
as you know my first instinct was it's
not
uh but i've been convinced and i think
the subsequent debate and discussion uh
has has kind of cemented that really if
i think if the built up area boundary
line was tight to the houses
along that road
i would be
maintaining my original position
but it's not
um
and
again i know members don't necessarily
want us to consider appeals but if this
does go to appeal we have to have a
strong reason um and that built up area
boundary line i i think it is my view
but i think that would cause us a
problem um so
we have a proposal to grant uh in line
with officer recommendation made by
cancer kendall seconded by myself uh we
will have to take that first so could i
have a show of hands for all those in
favor of granting in line with officers
recommendation
those
four
those against
two three four
six
six against so that fails
uh we therefore move to our second
proposal now i just want to make sure we
get our reasons for refusal correct
is it simply green belt
not in phil therefore inappropriate no
special circumstances
and not defining the ndp or not yes
okay hang on jeff what was the second
part
what do you mean
nothing's allocated in the ndp
thank you chairman let me try and
summarize what i think members are
advising us your saying that it's not an
allocated site in the buab
yes
yes um but you also feel that it doesn't
constitute infilling um and is therefore
inappropriate development in the green
belt
yes those are your reasons for refusal
accepting that the fact that it's not an
allocated site in the building doesn't
necessarily mean that it isn't therefore
still acceptable um in the
the buab simply because it's you know
with within that established boundary so
it doesn't have to be an allocated site
in order for it to still be acceptable
in uh ndp and by boundaries terms and i
don't think i mean correct me if i'm
wrong tracy but i don't think there are
any allocated sites in the neighborhood
plan
um in fairness i can't answer that
question either i'm not wholly familiar
with the uh
with with the terms of the uh the ndp
there
looking looking at the uh the plan which
stewart showed i don't think there were
any allocated
so um just
we have the ndp on screen here so i'm
just gonna have a quick look and double
check and then we will
if you look on bottom of page 59 about
potential infill sites
from the parish council you can scrum
just bear with me a second while i read
this and then i'll call you in
so we've very quickly skimmed through
that and
between myself and ross we can't see any
allocated sites given we have the crash
council here and we do have dispensation
to call them forward again just to uh
clarify a point of fact could i ask you
counselor ms to come forward and just
confirm whether there are or aren't any
allocated sites within the ndp
we haven't allocated any sites but it's
on
oh sorry it's it's on you guys
so the answer is no no okay
that's all i want to clarify thank you
i'm gonna have to stop you there because
i it was a point of fact you've answered
the point of fact
thank you very much
so that answers that question council
crump you wanted to come in and say
something yeah
it was just to do with page 59 um where
the crash council put the objection in
um
and it said in september 2014 the only
potential infill identified was perhaps
two dwellings between
rivendell to the west and old vicarage
so is that potentially an identified
site or
as we just had confirmed from the parish
council chairman
there are no allocated sites in the ndp
but this was
in the
the statement with it on page 59
says in september 2014
we're seven years on from that
and the ndp was made nine days ago i'm
going to rely on the fact that the ndp
is the latest document that's relevant
and we've had it confirmed that there
are no allocated sites within that
so i don't think there's any need to go
any further with points of fact
now we need to move back to
uh the reasons for refusal
which were
uh
not infill
there's a lot of people talking while
i'm trying to think and speak as you
know i'm not very good at multitasking
so please
let me get my words out and then we'll
get other people in
so
it was green belt policy not limited
infill and therefore inappropriate
development in the green belt
um you also said about that not being
allocated uh within the ndp i don't
think that as a standalone um reason for
refusal is sufficient i think the
infilling and inappropriateness in the
green belt can be supported by the ndp's
policies so our policies and the ndp
policies and that encompasses everything
i think that you said before are you
comfortable with that
account senator sheriff and you seconded
are you comfortable with that
are you guys comfortable with that
it's the greenbelt reason um but with
the ndp policies included within that
because it's not allocated
okay
we've got there we have our reasons for
refusal i think everyone understands it
council formal thank you can we mention
anything about the uh vineyard in that
as well or not
it's not i don't think uh saying it
could damage the vineyard when we have
no evidence to support that uh is an
appropriate thing to put in um
a valid thing to consider but not
necessarily an appropriate thing to put
it
okay
ross can i just check chester the reason
for refusal is that it's um it's not in
phil
therefore it's inappropriate development
in the green belt and there's no very
special circumstances have been correct
fine
you hopefully added the word limited
infill in your summary chairman which is
entirely correct because the phrase is
limited in filling in villages in
relation to greenbelt policy as set out
in the mppf so yes we would need to make
sure that that word limited that's part
of that uh definition as well thank you
we've got a thumbs up we've got a nod
from counseling serving as well let's
move to a vote shall we
all those in favor of refusal for the
reasons given
and those against
three and abstentions one so therefore
committee resolves to refuse application
21.01925
ful
the old vic ridge in barely
does anyone else would anyone else like
a quick adjournment or should we just
crack on
give him a minute when he comes back
all right
council crumb i'm going to ask you to uh
grab your seat again please we are all
back
okay
thank you very much everyone for your
patience okay let's move into our final
items this evening which is application
reference 2101 868 ful that is the old
smithy in uh bishops itchington our
presenting officer is stuart flair
teacher over to you
thank you chairman
this proposal is seeking full planning
commission for the erection of a
single-story rear extension and first
floor extension in addition to the
insertion of a front door and rear roof
light
uh the application site is within the
village of bishop zitchington as
indicated by this submitted location
plan
uh here we have the both the existing
and proposed uh front and side
elevations so the existing layout is
displayed here at the top uh the
proposed layout put before you this
evening is on the bottom
and likewise here we have the rear
elevation both existing at the top and
proposed at the bottom
we now have some
imagery of the site here we are stood
to the left here we are stood on the
junction of fisher road and the high
street looking at the main front
elevation
uh here on the photo on the right we see
this same dwelling to the rear
uh there's more imagery
showing the existing dwelling and how it
sits in the wider street scene
uh positive and productive discussions
have taken place between the applicant
consultees and this district to attempt
to find an acceptable solution uh for
this site offers a review this proposal
represents a commensurate and sensitive
addition to the property uh officers
consider that the proposal harmonizes
with the local character and as is an
acceptable design solution
uh i refer you all to the update sheets
just for a update to the parish's
response
written uh after the witty report was uh
closed down uh chairman the
recommendation is to grant this
application for the reasons set out on
page 78 of your agenda packs thank you
thank you very much uh we only have one
speaker
on this item who is kettle cancer castle
you want to make your way forward
you've been remarkably patient sitting
through three other items
probably a wise choice i think
uh you know the drill five minutes i'll
give you 30 second warning whenever
you're ready over to you
can i take up the whole five minutes
um members this is probably one of the
smaller applications you'll see but even
this one has its issues
both but the parish council and myself
have objected and maintain our
objections to this application but for
different reasons i am a member of the
parish council so i'm just going to
cover that in my in my section the
parish council objects the grounds uh on
on the grounds of cs-9 designers
distinctiveness converting the former
one-story butcher's shop
with a small uptest accommodation into a
full-up
two-story property
this is the old part of the village and
whilst not a conservation area is still
one where the officer in his report
refers to potential significant
archaeological remains
which is of course relevant under cs-8
building a new structure and the
increase in mass do not reflect the
contemporary design of this old part of
the village
it will create a visual hard impact
the application is squeezing the maximum
capacity onto a very small plot and is
not sympathetic
or of good design and i don't think we
actually saw a
a view in the office presentation
uh
an overhead view but there is further
development behind which you can just
see in the bottom right hand corner
there
so it isn't just the front going up
extending one and a half to two stories
two residents responding have referred
to the need and all villages for small
and more important affordable properties
as referred to in policy cs19 converting
a small one and a half story property
into a full up two or possibly three
bedroom as the snug was described in an
earlier plan for this site
withdrawn as a snug stroke bedroom it's
still there it's now called a snug
this removes this property from small
affordable niche which communities need
in their center
my also my own concerns also shared with
residents are twofold
the first from policy cs4 relates to the
not huge but significant increase in
roof area and how the water flow from
the increased area will be accommodated
the combined foul and surface water
drain
the drain in the street immediately
downhill downhill from the site has been
broken for many years
it already floods regularly into road on
on a regular basis in periods of heavy
rain
increasing the flow will exacerbate this
problem
there is no proposal for any form of sud
scheme and it sounds a bit grand for
such a small development
but it is a real problem
to mitigate it and therefore
what will have a significant extra roof
area
where is it going to go the second is
parking cs9 subsection 7 requires
development to minimize the danger from
traffic this site is 10 meters from the
junction between high street which is a
very narrow single track lane and the
other fisher road which is also narrow
you can't get two lorries to it
and has speed humps to flow slow traffic
down
is right on the corner by the pub and
the primary school
two full-size
um bedrooms and the option of the third
with which currently as we've mentioned
about the snug raises the question of
where will the new residents park
currently the former residents have had
room for one vehicle immediately outside
the door there is nowhere else
in summary this is an unwelcome
developer development of
a rather charming
small niche site which will bring no
benefit but considerable planning harms
the community and i think i'd like you
to concentrate on that harm
the visual impact which the parish has
referred the traffic impact which i've
referred to
the water impact which i think is very
relevant
and i might also add as a final thing
is where is the amenity area for this
expansion it is very small sorry the
officer has now put the overhead view on
it
it is it is tiny
for a two possibly three bedroom
property
thank you ladies and gentlemen
can i keep going or we need that you've
got 55 seconds i'll stop you can ask me
any questions you like i should have
just said five seconds
do we have any questions for cancer
cattle
go ahead castle mills
good evening council cattle um talk
about the immediacy um
would there be a parking issue there
with this extra so
with
sorry
uh it took about immediately will would
in your opinion be a parking issue there
the immediate area is
yeah i couldn't see the name smithing
when i looked there but uh
okay thank you any other questions for
cancer
no okay counsel thank you very much
thank you very much for your time and
contribution this evening if you could
please give the desk a quick wipe that
would be greatly appreciated
um do we have we're moving now into uh
points clarification for our officers do
we have any questions or points of
clarification we'd like to ask
councilman jennings first please there's
nothing from i'm looking there's nothing
from highways here am i missing that is
that because it's it's already a
two-bedroom house and it's just going to
be a slightly larger two-bedroom house
therefore it's not relevant
uh yes i can thank you uh councillor um
from what i have seen from the report uh
council highways weren't consulted and
haven't offered therefore offered a view
but you are correct in the second part
of your your your point um the dwelling
such that it is currently is a two-bed
dwelling
um you can see the layout uh upstairs a
fairly very small
second bedroom there is proposed to be a
re-jig an internal reefer but there will
remain two bedrooms
uh at this dwelling um i understand um
obviously councillor kessel has just
made representations uh on a previous
superseded plan
um i would remind everybody that these
are the plans both existing and proposed
that we have before us uh there is to be
two bedrooms and just finally on also on
that point uh as is already touched upon
there are no on-site parking spaces to
speak of currently um so
nor is there to be additional spaces
required by virtue of there being two
bedrooms currently and two bedrooms
proposed
if i may follow on from that obviously
highways was a concern of mine i can see
they haven't been consulted given this
is on a t junction surely it should have
they should have been consulted and if
they haven't been why not
um it's a fair question um i understand
obviously i've read the representations
received um
i can't give a
definitive answer from my colleagues in
the assistant planning team as to
where and when they they do consult the
county highways
team
um it is a
clearly parking is is a potential issue
and this has been communicated already
on this site um
i can't give you a dependency chairman
that's why they were i guess i guess my
my biggest concern is is visibility uh
as you're coming in and out of that um
junction just can you just confirm for
me that we're not external the proposal
isn't to extend the building
further
to the right as we see it on that
left-hand picture it is maintaining its
current floor print footprint that
that's correct yes we're building up on
that elevation uh here and on the uh
building upwards there's no increase in
footprint thank you council dixon
thank you chairman stuart um the drawing
we had showing the uh ex the increased
site of that uh extension
that's the one
um according to the uh report on page
the
76 the extension will still be subservient
to the ridge height by 300 mil which i
think is probably about our thought
um is that still actually the case
because it looks
doesn't look to be much different to my
mind on that bottom left-hand corner
um i can go
by what is written in the report uh the
ridge height that's being referred to uh
by my colleague is the one that where
which you've just touched on counsellor
it is this one and then views from a
slightly different angle this one here
um
it is uh put forward on the submitted
plans as sitting 300 mil below the main
ridge
um that is the detail that we've got
before us this evening
council crumb
just going on the parking spd so um if
we were going to increase again it's for
future clarification
because it's two bedrooms existing and
it's going to be two
bedrooms after the application there's
no reason to
take into current spd if it was a new
build we'd have to go for the spd is
that right um we'd have to ensure that
so yes it's just just clarification that
and if we went and again
prepared with me to on this if it went
to a three bedroom would we then have to
go to the spd so it's just a matter of
clarification for if it comes forward in
a similar situation
as well tonight chair
thank you councillor um
you are
your first your first point raised the
matter of if this were to be
a de facto let's say demolish and build
a new house uh with three bedrooms let's
say or a new three bed on this property
on this sighting sorry um it would need
to adhere to parking standards that are
detailed and you've touched on in the
sbd guidance uh that is guidance i must
stress but it's still something that we
look to as officers clearly um
your second question was if this were
hypothetically going from a two bed to a
bone five three bed uh
proposal um i think that would be
materially different to the schemas but
before us this evening i'd be loathed to
go
if we're talking hypotheticals um that's
a different matter i would say
just i accept the point why we're not
requesting any for this application
because it's gonna be two and two but
from a future reference point of view so
you don't get a silly questions like
this again um from eight to eight or
nine of us
would that have been the case
that is a fair summation that would
increase the potential hypothetical
parking standards uh requirements
you can probably see on page 77 the
highways matters section does refer to
that if they if it had been increasing
then it would need to meet that standard
unless we have any other points of
clarification let's move to the debate
oh sorry bill you're outside of my
periphery over there i'm sorry um
council fleming
i'd just like to ask a question on on
can you answer a question on the water
runoff that counts the kettle refree
referred to
um i can as best i can
he he was concerned about the amount of
extra water runoff the roof is going to
be exactly the same size so i'm trying
to work out where
more water will come from i don't know
whether you can answer that oh no i
think that we'll leave that and discuss
it in debate shall we
let's open up the debate
would you like to kick yourself that's
twice i've done that
yeah would you like to carry on on the
debate i can't see there being a a an
extra water runoff problem because the
roofs are going to be the same size so i
just wonder if anybody else has any
other comments on that i think i would
be inclined to agree with you the roof
is exactly the same size the amount of
rain that falls on there will be exactly
the same amount as it would be depending
regardless of the size of the roof
so yes i agree i'm not sure it's
necessarily a a relevant point um would
anyone else like to i'll tell you what
um i'll go
first this time um
i did
looking at those images and
understanding where this is uh in terms
of the the road layout i did have my
concerns i must admit it is on the edge
of a t junction but the reality is it's
not extending out further towards the t
junction it is just going up um given
there is already built form there i
can't see there being any uh conflict
with the highways i also have no issue
with any other aspects of it so i'm
going to propose with grant inline was
offers a recommendation counselor
kendall
beat me to a well second year good man
does anyone else want to say anything or
shall we go straight to a vote
it looks like we want to go straight to
a vote so could we have a show of hands
please for those in favor of granting
this
application looks unanimous to me yep
that is unanimous so um uh committee
therefore resolves to grant application
21 0 1 868 ful the old smithy in bishops
itchington
um and i believe unless we have any
urgent business which i don't think we
have
nope um i believe that's it so members
officers
people and members of the public thank
you very much for your time
contributions this evening kazakhstan
have you got a question
only in as much as
good
and the appeals
which overturned
shall we shall we should we close the
meeting first and then we can discuss
that afterwards so um thank you very
much everyone um the meeting is now
closed
thank you chairman yes the answer
basically